activists angrily calling for justice
protesting against an istanbul court's
decision to jail turkish businessman and
activist osman kavala for life kamala's
friends cried and hug as he was
convicted of trying to overthrow the
government by financing nationwide
anti-government protests in 2013. other
charges of espionage were thrown out
if this was a lawful decision we would
be able to comment on it but it's not
this is the summary of akb government's
revenge against gezi park protests the
pact courtroom watched on as seven of
cavalla's friends were convicted of
helping him and he jailed for 18 years
the manufactured charges and accusations
against the defendants should be dropped
kavala who's been behind bars for four
and a half years has always denied the
charges against him saying they are
politically motivated turkey's
government denies this but the european
court of human rights as well as
activists and turkeys western nato
allies say the trial and verdict are
part of a crackdown on descent under
president recep tayyip erdogan
the court's aggravated life sentence for
kavala must be approved by the court of
appeal and then the supreme court this
can take months or longer but this may
not be the end of the process for kavala
if the appeals court overturns the
verdict kavala may be released pending
trial for now friends and supporters
live in hope however narrow it is solo
al jazeera istanbul